Hello, everybody!
My name is Markiplier and welcome to 'Reading Your Tweets'!
Now I noticed something very peculiar about Twitter recently
Whenever I,
or anyone with a lot of followers would reply to someone on Twitter
it could be a normal, everyday conversation
Whatever it was, the other person would invariably
FREAK. OUT.
And the freak-outs range wildly from the mildly deranged
'WHAT GEE FUCK?'
to a complete disregard for the English language
'LIMICK EFOSUJ'
And I think it's become like a little game inside the community
To see who can freak out the MOST
when they finally get that reply that they've always wanted.
And I'm not knocking it
I'm not putting it down in any way
I think it's actually quite hilarious, even though in my mind
I imagine the- the tweet says:
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
And yet they're sitting on their toilet just like,
'I'm screaming,
oh my god, I'm literally dyin' '
So I thought what better way to celebrate this rather strange way of celebration
than to read these absolute bonkers, insane tweets
LIVE TO YOU!
It's not live...
this is... prerecorded
I CANT BREATEN
Oooohhhhh
Timir, Cockfifen, Fefoooskesnn
*revving car engine*
I'M SCREMWHUM
YHAYH JE' FUCKED
I'M CHIEF NEEKY!
MACKERD
I'm shook.
I CANNANT PESHKESZHUZJ
what?
MACRO jusjeurrjus TWEE-TOOGED ME?
britney liked your Tweet.
SHAELY
SHMKERSMGURSMNSK
Mark.
Eugh my god
OH JIMY GAWD
IHH, My todd
I can't bergetay! Three nununde what the cuck?
I'm screnibed!
I KNOW! I'M SCRANEVID!
Thank yoy, I'm shakibed.
OOOH DEMAA FAMUHDEZNUS
I'M ON MY FLOOR!
KeDIND!
DEE!
MARK I CANNER SHEJESKESM DICK!
A geeeese!
Sejisnum ojin, Goood, wuh
huh?
*click*
[Inception BWAH]
GOO! Why SHIT!
I WANST WIXPEX NNTHAT
*faint*
IM ABOU YIT
to CRU!
WHAT THE FLUCHE!
WUHMARY! I'M SKREEKING
I'm so HAPP.
... why?
*Sad existential music*
I'm littersolt crionf!
Guh, the sausages
*summoning the Darkiplier* HukSOHSKUSKUN SCKUSNUNNED
nope
I KAY WOUT I ME YOURA
Jede! Jede keskuh shudukuquolulu
OH MY FOD
I can't vleeb!
O'm naht oakee
Are vh You Fuxkin FFFBreathe??!
*ew*
I'm vruIIINNGG
I'm FUCKINGS croo-yab'nuh!
*Dying whale/horse sounds*
I CANT BEKEEV!
KIZUMMMMMMMMM-kay.
So that was just a sample of the freak-outs that I've seen on Twitter.
I've seen way worse
and I've seen way bigger than that
but I'm not going to bother reading paragraphs of random letters.
But this was a lot of fun
And I can totally see why you guys would freak out when your favorite YouTuber responds to you on Twitter
That's totally cool, but also remember that we're just real people
All of us YouTubers are just real people, so if we ever meet in person,
Don't spend our only interaction with each other shouting in my face *thump* that you're screaking
Sorry, don't mind that, I dropped my gerbil.
So I don't think I'm going to be doing another one of this specific type
I don't want to read all freak-outs all day long because that would get very boring, very quickly
with me just spouting SIMS language up here on the video but
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
I will do more of these 'Reading Your Comments' style videos in the future
but I like to mix it up a little bit
So thanks again everybody for watching
and as always, I will see you in the next video. Buh-byee!
*lovely ding to end the video*